immanuel kant is considered to be perhaps the
most important philosopher of all time, in
fact, in the eighteenth
century he made two great discoveries that
still keep us in suspense to this day,
on the one hand, he founded the globally
valid categorical imperative, on the
other hand, he was the first
philosopher to ever answer the age-old
human question of how
cognitions come about in our brain
in his major work the critique of
pure reason he examined over
1000 pages how the
human thinking apparatus works he
asked the critical question what can
man recognize with certainty
and what not
he worked like a man obsessed
and drew  back in his
study after eleven long years he
gave his answer to mankind and it had it all
our reason so kant is only able
to recognize with certainty what
we previously
saw, heard, smelled, tasted or
touch with our five senses  t
therefore one can
neither recognize nor prove god therefore has
no body and no perception
kant gave the researchers for the first time
a sensationally simple and perfect
logical instrument
that is still valid today and all
results are scientifically
comparable worldwide makes
every theory so good  it may
be so edgy it must always be provable by
observations, for example by repeatable
experiments
in his second major work the critique
of practical reason he made the
equally immodest attempt
to answer the question once and for all of
how best man should act
there is one  standard for ethically
correct
action here, too, one can come up with a
spectacular answer that still causes a stir around the world to this day
the
little book kant in 60
explains the two main works in a very
lively way using over 80
central quotations and many
examples i think gan  z discoveries
undoubtedly have enormous significance
for our society as a whole, but
also for our personal lives